I remember when you were born my lady
you were named for my aunt Lyanna who
said she was a great beauty I'm sure you
will be too
I doubt it my mother wasn't a great
beauty or any other kind of beauty she
was a great warrior though she died
fighting for your brother Rob hey guys
Pete here I had some time today so I
finally got a chance to fix the sound
for my Lyanna Mormont Game of Thrones
history video I got a lot of helpful
constructive criticism that the sound
was no good in my first release of this
and honestly I'm not that surprised
because I didn't really know what I was
doing but I took all the suggestions and
applied them to my newer videos and now
I'm gonna do this reboot of the liana
video if you haven't seen the Geo T
election campaign that they're running
on HBO's website they actually made
Lyanna Jon Snow's running mate
we met Lyanna Mormont in season six at
game of throne we had already heard
mention of her at that point but we'll
get to that later she is the head of
house Mormont from Bear Island and this
video will go into how she ended up in
that place what you have to understand
my ladies I understand that I'm
responsible for Bear Island all who live
here so why should I sacrifice one more
moment life is someone else's war we
first heard of Lyanna Mormont when
Stannis was at Castle black trying to
rally houses behind him in the war of
the five kings he sent out Ravens and we
see this note that house Mormont sent
back which says Bear Island knows no
king but the king in the north
whose name is stark Stannis goes on to
show this message to Jon and we learn
from him that Liana is like a 10 year
old that makes her interesting right
from the very start and it might make
you wonder at least it did me how she
ended up as the head of this northern
family to understand that we need to
take a look at her family history and
the family tree before we get into it
just keep in mind that things are
different in the books in the show when
it comes to the Mormont family and its
characters we know a few of them pretty
well from the show we know Jorah who
plays a big part in Daenerys storyline
and his father Jr who was Lord Commander
of the Nights Watch when Jon Snow first
goes to the wall on this map of the
north we see Bear Island is right here
in the bay of ice north of deep wood
mah Winterfell is down here so you can
see that they are very far away from
each other wall is up here so you can
see that there they're nearby and of
course the Starks have been ruled the
ruling house in the north throughout
most of history but there's also a like
a interesting bit of lore related to
bear island legend has it that a past
king of the north roderick stark won
Bear Island in a wrestling match against
an Ironborn guy who was holding it after
his victory
Roger gave the island house more month
since house Mormont isn't a major house
in Westeros we don't have a detailed
history about them in the world of Ice
and Fire book but we do get a lot of
anecdotal stories about different
members of the family we have seen Leon
his mother Mage Mormont in the show
already though she traveled to fight
beside Robb Stark in the war and we get
to see her in this clip where Rob is
named king of the north she stands out
in this crowd so I don't think you'll
have any trouble figuring out which one
she is what do they know of the wall or
the wolfswood and their gods are wrong
we'll talk about mage more in a minute
cuz she's a super interesting character
but right now let's look through the
complete Mormont family tree based on
what we know I will start out with the
characters we know best in the show and
then go all the way down the line to
Leona
this chart shows all the more months we
know about junior moment is an important
character you might not you might have
forgot about since he died off quite a
while ago in the show Game of Thrones we
don't know anything about Junior's wife
but we do know he has one son as
mentioned gr was the Lord Commander of
the Nights Watch when Jon first arrived
at the wall even though Jon
distinguished himself as one of the most
skilled fighters in his group of
recruits junior decided to post him with
the Stuart John was definitely pissed
off about this but we find out later
that giora had planned to make him his
personal steward so that he can groom
him for command G or is Liana's uncle
and before taking the black heat was the
head of House Mormon when his son Jorah
came of age G or decided to abdicate his
seat so that his son could become the
lord of Bear Island he went to the wall
and joined the watch where he quickly
rose through the ranks to become the
nine
97th Lord Commander jorah mormont is a
character we all know as he has been in
every single season of Game of Thrones
Jorah in the books in the show is a
character who seems really honorable at
times but at best has made some poor
decisions in his lifetime Jorah married
his second wife Lynette Hightower after
winning the tourney at Lannisport while
he was wearing her favor
after crowning her the queen of love and
beauty Jorah asked her father for
permission to marry her even though she
could have married into a much more
prominent family her father said yes
their marriage turned out to be the
beginning of the end for Jorah though
since his new bride was accustomed to a
higher lifestyle coming from one of the
wealthiest families in the reach tour
ended up getting himself into financial
trouble trying to keep his bride happy
at bear island and eventually got caught
selling some poachers he captured in the
slavery slave trading is a criminal as a
crime punishable by death and Jorah
decided to flee rather than facing
justice from how stark
he left his ancestral family Valyrian
steel blade long claw behind because of
his dishonor Junior reclaimed the blade
and brought it to the wall with him it
but never like to look at it since it
remind him of the shame that djor had
brought on their family after john saves
his life he has long caught refashion
with the wolf's head pommel and gives it
to john who still wields it now so we
saw a mage in the clip before and when
Jorah fled she became the head of house
Mormont in the books we learned a lot
about mage and her daughters and for
show Watchers this is where things get
pretty interesting mage is known as the
she-bear she's a large stocky woman and
as we found out from the liana clip she
is a warrior we actually know that all
what Mormont women grow up to be
warriors because it's said that they
learn to fight at an early age to defend
themselves against invading iron men and
wildly mage Mormont has five daughters
whose father is unknown this is most
likely because her mate wasn't a lord or
a highborn person and in that case she
would keep their her own family name I
had a lot of questions about this in the
comments of the original original video
so I address it in more detail in the
liana Q&A video I made what you should
check out after you watch this book mage
and show mage have different storylines
when Leona meets with Sansa and John she
actions that her mother died fighting
for their brother Rob in the books we
aren't a hundred percent sure where she
is but there is no indication that she
died anyways May's left Bear Island when
Rob called his banners in the war of the
five kings and traveled south to fight
in the books both mage and her oldest
daughter were on their way to attend the
red wedding but mace took off on a
different mission and didn't go
unfortunately desi Mormont was acting as
one of Rob's Kingsguard and was killed
along with him at the wedding itself we
don't know a whole lot about desi except
that she had said that she was the most
elegant of mages daughters Stacey was
six feet tall and accounts say she was
comfortable dressing like a war warrior
just like her other sisters but was also
at ease dressing like a lady
we know she died from an X to the belly
at the twins as a member of Rob's
Kingsguard but we don't have many other
references about her to go off of major
2nd daughter Allison on the other hand
is a character we know quite a bit about
from the books she ends up marching
towards Winterfell with Stannis's army
and he has her watch over his his
prisoner Asha Greyjoy who we know as
Yara Greyjoy in the show she tells you
ro she has two children a daughter and a
son and again we don't know anything
about the father one of the most
interesting things here is Alison tells
her that the father is a bear in fact
she says that all the Mormont women are
skinchangers and they could they can all
turn into bears basically that means
they can go out and mate with theirs if
they want to this story and the fact
that mage is named the she-bear had a
lot of people asking about whether
tormund Giantsbane Giantsbane theory was
real
it's a story he tells John about
sleeping with a bear there's two
different theories you know one involves
mage and one involves Alassane but they
both boil down to him sleeping with one
of them and being a father to one of
their children I broke this theory down
a lot more in my Lyanna Q&A so I'm not
going to go into it again here Alison is
still alive in the books but the story
is completely different since Stannis is
also still alive in the books as well I
don't think she'll be involved with the
show at this point at all so I think we
can rule her out as you know coming home
in bumping Liana out as the head of the
house there are two more sisters in the
books Lyra and jor-el who Alassane
mentions to Yara that there with her
mother we don't have any other
information about them which also means
I don't think we'll ever meet them in
the show and I don't know where they're
at in the book so I can't say that
brings us to the little bear Liana as
far as the family tree goes she's way at
the bottom she is a daughter on the
second side as in her mother would have
never been the head of house Mormont if
her brother's son hadn't fled or if
Jorah would have had some children of
his own since her mother and all her
older sisters went south she was left in
charge it's similar to how bran was left
behind in Winterfell and you know we see
that with the aid of their maesters they
can handle the family's affairs now
Lyanna Mormont is the head of the house
and as we've seen in the show she
doesn't mince words
your son was butchered at the red
wedding Lord monthly but you refused to
call you swore allegiance to House Stark
Lord of you refuse the call and you Lord
Kerwin your father was skinned alive by
Ramsay Bolton still you refuse the call
but house Mormont remembers the North
remembers we know no king but the king
in the north whose name is stark I don't
care if there's a bastard that starts
good runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day
so that is everything we know about the
little bear and how she got to where
she's at
I made the first video before she put
John up as the king of the north and now
it seems like the show could probably
use her a lot more in the last two
seasons obviously she's a fun character
and the actor is great but I think one
of the things that makes her extra
awesome is that at her age she's in a
position to act in a very
straightforward and honorable way kids
in some ways living a world outside the
influence of politics and even though
they can be extreme and they're
idealistic view of things it seems like
that could be actually a good influence
on the heads of the other northern
families I don't know what the future
holds for Liana but I think it's a good
sign that the show's creators have made
her John's running mate in the campaign
promotion on their site that said I
don't think she'll be married to John
Snow in the show primarily because of
her age while it's pretty normal for
women to get married very young in
Westeros the show that already made the
conscious decision to make the
characters older than they were in the
books like for example Daenerys is only
about 13 when she's married off to call
Drogo and they had to change that to go
along with our modern cultural norms
since she ends up getting pregnant with
his child so let me know what you think
in the comments and make sure to watch
my Lyanna QA video for more about the
torment theory and all the other
questions that people ask about Liana
and the Mormont family thanks again for
the feedback on the sound I hope this
one came out a lot better please like
the video if you found it interesting
and subscribe to my channel for more
game of Thrones and A Song of Ice and
Fire videos I have a bunch plan that I'm
going to be putting out this month and I
hope that you'll come and check them out
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon